hello and welcome to this visual studio
code
vs code crash course where you are going
to learn all the ins and outs of the
best and most popular and most powerful
editor for
web development my name is james q quick
and i run
a youtube channel at jamesquick on
youtube where i do web development
tutorials every week so you can go and
check that out if you're interested
in the meantime let's go ahead and get
started breaking down all of the ins and
outs of vs code in this crash course
so before we dive in and actually show
you what vs code looks like and what
it's all about
i want to start by just kind of talking
about what it's about so
visual studio code is in my mind the
most
popular and most powerful text editor
there is especially in the realm of web
development
so if you look at what vs code is it's
not a fully fledged ide
or integrated development environment
it's not like eclipse is for java or
intellij is for java or for visual
studio is
for c-sharp and windows related
activities
visual studio code is more of a
lightweight text editor so you can
compare this to something like atom
or brackets or notepad plus plus etc
the really cool thing about vs code is
that it's cross-platform which means it
runs on mac
windows and linux and you can see here
it's got a download button that says
download for mac for me
because it's automatically detecting
which
operating system i'm currently on now
some of the cool behind the scenes stuff
of why that's possible is vs code is
actually built with something called
electron js so electron js
allows you to build desktop applications
using web technologies javascript html
and css which is really really neat
so vs code i think is one of the best
examples of how you can build a really
powerful
and really performant application that
can do a lot of things that you'll learn
more about here in a few minutes
with your basic web technology so
electron is really
amazing in that sense and that allows vs
code to now be cross platform which
means regardless of what operating
system you're on
you can download vs code and you can
start working with it from there
so i kind of mentioned vs code is i
would say the most popular text editor
in web development which means it's
great for doing html
css javascript doing react or node
or php or python things like that
but it can do a lot more than just those
languages it can it can work with java
it can work with c-sharp it can work
with
net core it can work with markdown for
example we might see a little bit of
that in this crash course as well
you can work with almost anything inside
of vs code and that's the real power
behind it where
it's really lightweight it's super fast
to start up but it's also very powerful
where you can add features through their
extensions which we'll see more of here
in a little bit
to be able to support different
workflows different languages different
frameworks
that sort of thing so if you scroll down
you see some of their
core features here intellisense we'll
look at debugging we'll take a quick
look at some of the built-in git
features being able to work with
source control locally with git and then
work with github and other things like
bitbucket and things like that and then
the extension ecosystem the things that
you can add to vs code to just make it
more powerful
is really the beauty of this thing so
you've got some testimonials in here you
can scroll down and kind of read some
more of this but i think
the main thing we want to see here is
just this actually being hands-on
now the one thing i do want to show you
is that there's two different versions
of vs code there's kind of the
the stable edition that's what you see
here the stable build
and then there's also the insider's
edition now the insider's edition
is a version of vs code that really
shows you the latest code that's coming
out from the vs code developers
on a daily basis and what this means is
you'll get some extra features some new
features
but they may not work all the time
because these are things that they're
testing out
before they officially ship it to the
stable version
so this is for early adopters this is
for people who really want to try the
latest and greatest features
they don't mind if they get an
occasional broken build here so things
might go wrong
but i can tell you from my experience i
have used the vs code insider's edition
for months at a time and never had any
issues so you can kind of take that for
what it's worth
but you'll get these frequent builds at
least every day with new features and
bug fixes
and the cool thing is you can install vs
code
stable edition as well as the insider's
edition
both on your laptop and or your computer
and not have any issues so you can try
out some of those latest and greatest
features and then also go back to the
stable version if you want to
so to get started with vs code you'll
download this you'll run through some of
the setup stuff and then when you open
it you'll see kind of a welcome screen
so let me go ahead and open up
vs code on mine and you'll see how
quickly this loads especially in
comparison this is
actually going to seemingly take longer
than it did because it pulled up on
another screen
but one of the things that i really like
is when you open vs code it's going to
show you
often some updates of what became new
that month so the stable edition comes
out with new features and these are
pretty powerful features
every single month and they give you
this kind of newsletter to show you what
all is new
and you can see in here it has like even
images and animated videos
so vs code just does a really great job
of one adding features and taking
feedback on which features to add
but then also communicating and let you
know as they do this on a monthly basis
what things have changed so if you open
this up for the first time you can close
that out you'll also have kind of a
welcome message or welcome
page this will show you your recent
projects that you've worked on before
some help you can get the access to the
keyboard cheat sheet we'll talk a lot
about
keyboard shortcuts in here there's tips
and tricks and different things that you
can work on
there's some features or some sections
in here on how to customize
to set up support for other languages
than just javascript so python and java
php
working with azure as a cloud platform
and
docker as a container system if those
things don't mean anything to you
that's okay because you don't need to
worry about it those are extra things
that you can customize and use in vs
code
but you absolutely don't have to so
probably the first thing that you would
do
in vs code is go ahead and open a folder
now i'm opening a project called dev
setups which is one that i've been
working on recently
which allows users to upload an image of
their desk setup and you can kind of
scroll through and see different
people's setup so this is just kind of a
fun project that i've been working on
and i've got this thing open in here and
we'll kind of use this
as a way to just kind of poke around and
show you more about the editor
now the first thing you'll see this is
i'm going to close this welcome tab here
is you've got this sidebar over here
with several different icons and the top
one
is probably what you're looking for to
get started
and this just shows you all of the files
that you have inside of this open
project
so i've got this dev setups folder this
project open
and you can see here are all of the
files that are inside of this project
now if you're if you're new to react if
you're new to javascript don't worry
about what these files do specifically
just know that this is where you would
go and see all of those files
so in addition to the file explorer you
also have a search
icon so you can go and search through
your project if i wanted to search for
react for example this is a really
powerful feature in here
where this will show me everywhere that
react is inside of this project you can
see it's a lot
and then i can go in and actually do a
replace for example
of replacing this with um something
else it doesn't really matter and the
cool thing is vs code will show you kind
of in line what that replace will do so
react will become something else
this is not something i want to do so
i'm going to go ahead and back out of
that
so we'll talk a little bit more about
search and replace in a minute
but you come down you also have a source
control tab so as you make changes and
we'll cover some of the basics of this
you'll see the files that are changed
you'll see the files that are ready to
be committed
you'll see ones that have been staged
and so on and so on so all of your git
stuff you can do
right inside of vs code which is really
nice there's also
a debugging section down here so this
allows you to do like a true debugging
experience
where you can have break points and
inspect variables and all that sort of
stuff
and then lastly you'll come down and see
there's the extensions
tab and this is where you can search for
extensions to add different pieces of
functionality
to your vs code instance now the couple
of a couple of tabs i have down here
these are extra ones that i have
installed from extensions
so we don't need to cover that but when
you start off you'll see these four
right here and you'll also notice that
your vs code probably color wise looks a
little bit different
a little bit different so we'll cover
themes here in a minute and i use the
cobalt 2 theme so if you want to go
ahead
and look at this yourself you can go to
the extensions tab
you can search cobalt 2 and then when
you get to an extension
you can click to install it and it'll be
ready to go and yours will start to look
a lot more like mine
but i will cover some of the different
things that i have customized in mine
here in a second
so one of the things that i think is
really neat with vs code is you can kind
of customize the way things look and
your space that you're working with
with using shortcuts this is one of my
favorite things so let me open up
here's an app.css file so here's a
random css file
and i can do command b
on mac or control b on windows and for
all the shortcuts that i mentioned going
forward command
will be on mac and control will be the
equivalent on windows
so i will probably just stick with
command or i'll say command
and control and you'll know command is
for mac and control is for windows
so with that said command control b
allows me to toggle open this sidebar
and this is really nice because as a
developer
i might want to look at my files here
but then as i start to write code i
might want that to go away so i have
more room to actually write the code
that i care about
so i use command b command control b to
toggle this open
all of the time and then you can take
that one step further if you hover
over these icons you can do command
shift e to go directly to the explorer
or you can do command shift f to go
directly to finder
or the search and replace you can do
command shift
g actually this one specifically is
control shift g
so control shift g on both windows and
mac for the source control
and then command shift d to go straight
to debugging and then lastly again
command b
to make that toggle the sidebar menu
open and close completely which is
pretty nice
now you also will get some information
down here on this bottom bar
i've got a few extensions installed so i
get a little bit more
information than what you will probably
see but you'll have a little bit of
information about
probably the branch that you're working
on so in this case i'm working in a
master branch
inside of this repository and it shows
me down there which one i am working on
so you get a little bit of information
down there and you'll get a little bit
of information up here to show you which
file you're working on
now i want to show you a couple of cool
things with working with files
there's a grid tab system in vs code
where i can open
a file you can have two files open at
one time and then
also i can drag these over to the side
and notice you get this kind of darkened
effect that splits the screen
well i can have two files side by side
and i can resize these to any
combination of sizing that i want
so not only can you have two files side
by side you can also bring out
files in a grid system with
rows and columns so now i've got two
went to pane side by side and then on
the right side i've split that top and
bottom
and not only can you do that you can
also customize how those are laid out as
well
so you can get as crazy about this as
you want to with just
adding on more and more files
and i don't know that there's really a
limit here but at a certain point it's
not really practical to have all these
files
but here's three going vertically on
this column and then two over here
so you can do this any combination of
that you want
i typically stick with just having two
files side by side i don't usually use
multiple rows i typically just use two
different columns and
i didn't show this but you can also take
a window over here and have three
side by side and however many you want
so it's only so practical depending on
the size of your screen but you have the
flexibility to kind of make that your
own which is really nice
all right one thing i want to let you
know is your kind of holy grail your
master command
inside of vs code is going to be the
command palette so this is command shift
p
or control shift p and after you do that
you have the ability to kind of search
for whatever you want any command that
you can run
inside of vs code you can do from here
so one of the things i want to show you
is something called
zen mode under view so view toggle zen
mode
and what zen mode will do is basically
get rid of all the fluff so
all of the border items up here all the
sidebar all of that stuff is completely
gone
and now i can just focus on my code lots
of people love this feature where
they've got no distractions they just
see code
i don't personally use this because i
don't get too distracted by the other
stuff going on
but i think this is a pretty cool
feature inside of vs code to be able to
use so i'm going to toggle this
back off by running that command again
from the command palette
again command palette is going to be
your savior you can always go to the
command palette and search for anything
that you're looking for
now another thing that you'll see is on
yours by default you will probably see
this mini map thing over here
and this is extremely useful if we get
into what's a bigger file
in here do we have a big file so if we
have a much bigger file like this the
minimap over here will allow you to kind
of scroll through
all of these lines of code pretty
quickly so instead of having to scroll
with my mouse wheel over here you can
just kind of select and really jump to
wherever you want
inside of your code pretty quickly so i
don't leave the minimap on just because
i don't want to take up space
in my instance of vs code but you can
leave minimap there
and use it to jump around really big
files now again going to
the command palette you have the ability
to toggle on
the minimap and add it or get rid of it
so you can do that just like that
alright i mentioned search and replace
so we started by doing this over in the
left over here
but we can also do this right inside of
a file so if i wanted to
search for center i could do command
f and this will open the find window and
i can type in
center for example i can also and you
may have noticed it did this before
if i get rid of this and i select a
piece of text and then do command
f it will go ahead and automatically
populate that with that piece of text
which is really neat
you can also from here go down and say
all right instead of center i want to be
right
and i don't think this is a valid
property for justified content
but that's not really the point so
inside of here i can
do a replace of one instance or a
replace of
all so if you remember the shortcuts for
this
you can actually do some search and
replace stuff really really powerfully
and really quickly and easily inside of
vs code
all right so i could run this and do a
replace you see that replaces right
there
now this is obviously in just one file
you can also do the same sort of thing
inside of what we showed earlier where i
could search for
center for example and everywhere i have
center
not something i probably want to do i
could replace this with write
you can see all the instances of where
that is and you can even
by file by file say all right in this
specific file
in tailwind.js replace all of the
instances of center with write in just
that file
so you can go by file by file or line by
line you can click on these and go to it
and make a decision on whether or not
this is something you actually want to
change
and vs code does a really cool example
of showing you you're going to change
this
line to this line by replacing center
with
write so the search and replace stuff in
vs code is really really powerful
you can save yourself a lot of time if
you understand some of the shortcuts of
how to trigger the search and replace
and then go ahead and act on them so
speaking of shortcuts
we've mentioned a few already we
mentioned command or control b to toggle
open this window
there's also a few neat ones where you
can do command w
to close a file i use this a lot and
then
also if you have two files open or
multiple files open whatever these are
you can control tab to switch through
these files so you can toggle through
them like this i use this a lot as well
you can also do control shift tab to
toggle back the opposite way
so if i've got a bunch of different
files open up here and i want to go from
profile to home
that's good but if i want to go from
profile to tailwind css i can do it
backwards
by doing control shift and tab to go and
see that pop up as well
so control tab and control shift tab on
mac
and windows will allow you to toggle
through those files
now another thing that i do a lot is i
do command p
to open up or to search files to open
them so if i want
to search for my app js i will do
command p
i'll type the name of that file and then
enter and it will open that thing for me
now i usually leave this sidebar closed
so that i have more space for code
and then i just come in and do this
where i can search for the file
press enter and now i've got that file
open right here and then i can command
w or control w to close a file and then
i can toggle through that using these
control tab and control shift tab
shortcuts to go forwards and backwards
i think one of the main things main
pieces of advice that i have for people
that are writing code is learn to use
your shortcuts
it will save you a lot of time writing
code the less amount of time you spend
on a
mouse the more time you spend on your
keyboard the better off your you'll be
and the more productive you will be all
right so a couple of other things i want
to share with you is just how to
uh work is just how to navigate through
your text
so what i mean is if i want to go from
right here to right here
i don't want to have to click so i could
just arrow over so i could
type the arrow key a bunch of times
that's not really productive
or i could start to use some shortcuts
to help me navigate this text
so if you hold down option and press
left or right what this will do is it
will navigate
word by word and that word is kind of a
loose definition where like this thing
is a word this thing is a word
this is kind of a series of connected
characters so it really just kind of
goes by where the space
is so you can navigate word by word this
way
you can also hold down on mac you can
hold down command
and go left or right to get to the
beginning and end of a line so this is
really helpful as well
now you can also hold down command and
go top or bottom or
up and down to get to the top or bottom
of the file
and on a windows machine i think you can
do
control and then home and end to do the
same sort of thing so home and end will
take you to the beginning and end of a
line
if you hold down your control and do
that you can get to the top
or bottom of a file as well so you might
have to play around with that to get
kind of comfortable in doing that
but it is really really helpful if you
can start to learn to use your shortcuts
to navigate through text quickly
you can save yourself some time keep
your hands on the keyboard keep them off
of the mouse and really become a much
more productive
programmer so i want to make sure that i
undo
all of these changes and i can do that
with command or control z
so i can hold that down and undo all the
changes that i just made
you can also as you would probably
expect if you've used other editors you
can
select a line and do command c or
control c and then
command or control v to paste you can do
that
but even cooler you don't have to select
the line so if i'm on this line and i
want to copy this entire thing
i can just do command c and then command
v so i don't even have to select it
it will basically inherently select the
entire line by itself
now another one of my favorites is you
can use command
d or control d to select the actual word
that you're on
so if i wanted my character was inside
of this word i could use command d
then i could use command f to be able to
search that thing
and then i could go and replace it with
something else if i wanted to as well
so again learning these shortcuts
learning how to work with them will
really save you some time
now another thing that will save you
some time in vs code
is the built-in intellisense that vs
code provides you so what i mean is if i
start
typing in document you see i get a bunch
of things pop
open here but if i'm working with the
document element
object inside of javascript and i press
dot
now vs code knows that this thing is the
document
object and i can scroll through to see
all the different things i can do with
this document object
so if i scroll down you can see the
difference in these little icons here
this little purple one
those are actually functions so a common
thing you'll do in javascript is add an
event
listener so i could press enter on this
and if i open up the parentheses to go
ahead and call this function you can see
vs code is also giving me some
intellisense on what
parameters are required here so the
first parameter
is going to be a type so you can see
things like
there's 86 more there's a ton in here so
these are the different events that you
can listen for
and it's saying that that thing is a
type of event and then the
the second thing you pass is an actual
callback function
so if i type in click notice it's giving
me intellisense in here so not only can
i get click i can get close and can play
and cancel on those sort of things
and then if i go down to the second
parameter
i can read through this documentation to
show me what all is needed
including the callback which is the
second part so intellisense is something
that i
use all of the time because as a
developer i don't necessarily want to
write every single word or every single
character every single line of code
i would rather have a tool take care of
assisting that for me
and vs code does a really really great
job of providing you really powerful
intellisense
that you can use to save yourself a lot
of time now another really cool feature
i'm going to get rid of all of these
changes
another feature that i like a lot is i'm
going to add a new file in here we
haven't really shown how to do new files
but
if i click the new file up here i can
get a new
test html and i love
this feature right here it's a feature
called emmett which is built into vs
code but emmett is its own
thing so if you look up emit snippets in
here you can go to docs.imit.io
and you can learn a lot more about this
but basically it's powerful shortcuts
that you can use for your html and css
so if i do the bang character here it
shows me vs code does with intellisense
that there's an
emit abbreviation for this and this will
give me the boilerplate code
to an html file that's really powerful i
couldn't write all of this stuff from
scratch myself personally
so i use this little bang character
snippet
to generate the boilerplate stuff or
code for an html file
now you can take this several many steps
further
if i type in an h1 for example and press
enter that comes from emmet so i could
do that this
is in h1 i can also if i wanted
a div with a class of container i could
do div dot
container and this will add a class to a
div
with that class of container that's
pretty cool i could also do
div with an id of contamin i'm not very
creative so i could do container here as
well so there's the div with an id of
container
i could also do a div with a class of
container and an id of something special
again i'm not super creative here
there's an id and a container
and what's even cooler is if i undo this
and go back and get rid of div
and then finish typing this out div is
kind of implied here so if i don't
specify the element that i'm creating
it will infer it as a div so i could
also do an h1 with a class of title
and then the id of
cool title or something like that so it
does all of that stuff in line
you can also repeat stuff so if i did a
ul inside of that ul i could do an li
times three and that will generate three
lis for me
you can do an input with a type of text
there's
all sorts of these snippets to make
writing your html
so much quicker and easier
it's really worth looking and spending
some time
to figure out how to leverage the power
of emmett to help you generate snippets
or use snippets to generate your html
code
now you can also do this in your css i'm
going to get rid of
this file so i'm going to get rid of
this thing and then i'll open up
a css file so so i'm going to try to
create
a new test css file in here
and if i start off with targeting every
element for example
if i wanted to set the cursor as a
pointer notice i type cur
and i get some intellisense with emmett
abbreviations for cursor pointer
i could do a padding so if i type in p
that will
give me a lot of things in here well
this is just kind of regular
intellisense
but if i finish typing p10 for example
notice that autocompletes to padding of
10
or if i do m10 things like that so emit
is really really powerful for you to be
able to create
html css code using these really short
code
these really nice short codes or
snippets and save yourself
a lot of time and energy as well so you
definitely want to spend a little bit of
time just kind of figuring out
how to use emmet to work best for you
now let's talk about some vs code
settings so if you're really kind of
interested in what i have set up here
and how i have this set up let's go and
look at
my settings and so you can open the
settings by going to this cog wheel over
here or
you can do command comma or control
comma to open up your settings panel
so let's start with just the font family
so i have in here
installed on my machine something called
cascadia code let me pull that up for
you
cascadia code this is a free font by
microsoft that is really really nice
so you can install this cast this
cascadia code font
and then you can choose to use it inside
of your font family here
now just to show you if i were to get
rid of this so if i cut that and now
come back to my code
this looks very different so this is
kind of the default stuff that's set up
in vs code
but i like to have that really fancy
cascadia code
here and now it looks better so notice
also
that as i save or update these settings
vs code is reloading in real time
to show you those new changes which is
really really nice
another thing i love with my font is i
have something called
font ligatures turned on and this is
an example of a setting that you have to
change
directly inside of the settings.json
file so not just
inside of your vs code editor and you
see i've got lots that are changed in
here
but i can set the font ligatures to true
and font ligatures are
these cool little combination of
characters that i really enjoy
so let me show you a couple of examples
of this you can type
double equals now see that becomes one
character there instead of two if i do a
triple character now it becomes a three
barred
thing if i do a not equals now
this will come together like that and if
i do a not
equal equals you can see that comes
together too you also get a little arrow
icon so if you do arrow functions in
javascript you can get that as well
so this is a personal preference i think
font ligatures are really cool but
if you don't like the way those look you
can turn those off by coming into your
settings json
and then just turning that thing to
false i think they come false by default
so you may not even have to worry about
it
so another thing you can look at is your
font size i love how easy it is in vs
code to just search for your property
see what the different things are that
you can change and then change that
right here
so i've got my font size set to 20. if i
bump this up for example to 40
now my code is going to look a lot
bigger which is probably not very
practical but this is really easy to
just change if you're doing a demo or
something
and you want to be able to show people
your code now you can also change your
zoom
level so if i type in a 4 for example
notice this is going to zoom in vs code
as a whole
so this is going to make everything
bigger again if you're doing a demo
for example and you want people to be
able to see every part of vs code a lot
bigger
you can do that with your zoom level i'm
going to turn this back down to two to
make sure that i can see this
comfortably
now you can also do a command or control
and plus
or minus to zoom open as well and you
see that when i do that you see the
change in here
so you can do that with your shortcuts
or through the settings just like that
all right there are tons of different
settings in here that you could change
one of the ones that i like is a word
wrap so what that
means is if i have a line of code
that goes really really far and i'm just
typing out kind of dummy code here
notice after i cross this bar it wraps
over to the next line
so i personally like to have this turned
on so that i don't have to scroll
horizontally to see the end of it a line
of code and you can notice if i
turn off on here uh now i have to scroll
to be able to see this
i personally don't like that so i
usually leave word wrap on
now you can also set the word wrap
column so notice this bar over here is
set to 80.
if i set this bar to 4 for example this
is going to look terrible
now if i set this to the word wrap
column
now this thing is going to wrap my stuff
at four characters which is probably not
what you want even if i set this to 40
that's still gonna look a little tough
there to see so i'm gonna reset this
back to 80
and then i'm going to turn this back to
kind of regular
and uh now again you can see this is
wrapping at this line and it has that
line to show you
what is there all right there's some
other cool settings down here if you do
um anything with your files over here
you can tell vs code to not show you
certain
files so you can add a pattern in here
and i can add node modules for example
and this directory should just disappear
after i do that
so notice node module is not no longer
showing inside of that
and then i can just undo that by getting
rid of
this setting here by clicking this x on
node modules now that thing has come
back and you get a really
really kind of powerful ability to
customize this thing here
all right you can scroll through and and
do tons of different settings in here
i'll show you a few more as we go
through
one of the ones that i like is the
cursor uh to be blinking and you can
have this to be
and expand as well so this is just kind
of a cool effect
where you can see my cursor will kind of
expand there i think that's kind of nice
and then you can also set your cursor
style to a line or a block for example
now this thing is a lot thicker on that
letter that's actually kind of wild i've
never done that one before
so you can customize so many things in
vs code it's really really nice i would
i would recommend just spending some
time inside of these settings to really
try to get things the way that you think
uh work best for you all right that said
let's move into
extensions and themes and let's start
with themes because these are going to
be
extensions themselves and they can kind
of show you how to customize the look
and feel of your editor
even more so i mentioned that i use the
cobalt 2 theme so you can
search this and search cobalt 2 and then
this is the official theme by westboss
and so after you install that theme then
you can select it
and use it so you can you get a button
in here for set color theme you can also
go to your magical command palette with
command shift p and if you search
theme now you can scroll down to the
color theme
press enter and now you can choose and
watch this as i scroll through
vs code will update in real time to show
you what these different themes will
look like
and you can see there's a ton of really
cool different ways that you can do this
night owl is one of my favorites this is
from sierra drastner i like night owl a
lot
and this has a couple of different
versions so you have night owl with no
italics there
you've got this red theme i can't
imagine really working with that but
it's a cool one
shades of purple is a really nice one as
well from a mod a wise hopefully i'm
pronouncing that right
so he created this thing because he's a
big fan of purple and i actually think
it looks really really cool
uh they're solarized dark and these are
oh another one i want to show you is
winter is coming by john papa i really
like
this one a lot as well i think this is a
really really nice
kind of dark theme here so you can
search for tons of different themes you
can search for the ones
i just mentioned night owl here you get
that one there and
then winter is coming so there's the
winter is coming one
so if you just search themes in here now
you can come and see a ton of different
things that you can try out there's a
linux
set of linux themes in here there's
duotone
dark themes there's the zeppelin themes
that's kind of wild and cool
there's tons of themes in here they're
really easy to install you just click a
button
to install and then you go into your
settings and you choose which theme you
want to be active
so i'll let you kind of play around i
showed you a couple of my favorites you
can go in here and look for a bunch of
different ones and go from there
now let's talk about some other awesome
extensions that you're absolutely going
to want to have
here's a few that i really like there's
an extension called prettier
which does code formatting in vs code so
you can install this extension and then
also come in to your settings
and say format on save so this is a
combination of using an extension
as well as a setting for this and if you
set this to true
what's going to happen or if you check
this what's going to happen is it's
going to use prettier
and it's going to format my code every
time i save so if i
kind of mess up some of the tabs in here
and i put this stuff like
all over the place and it this just
looks like really terrible code
when i save this now it's going to
format all of that stuff for me
so the combination of using prettier as
an extension as well as the setting in
vs code
for format on save is incredibly
powerful
i do this for all of my projects so this
is definitely one that's worth having
i also use an extension called advanced
new file
and what this allows me to do if i come
and grab
the right one so this is the one with
dashes what this allows me to do
is instead of coming over here
and choosing to click to add a new file
i can run
my new file command so advanced new file
if i run that it gives me a drop down to
choose which directory i want to put
this file
in so i could put this in the workspace
root and then i could call this test.js
and then now that file is created and
you can see that over here again i look
for any excuse to use shortcuts and
extensions to help me do stuff
versus coming over and actually clicking
on things with a mouse so that's one of
the ones that i use
a lot myself as well another one i find
handy is the better comments
extension what this will do is allow me
in my code to write different types of
comments like
to do and it will highlight that
different color so if i say
something like exclamation that's going
to turn this thing red
and there's also a star for a green
comment and then if you define something
as a param
it will highlight that or color that as
well so i think this is really useful
for you to be able to leave code
comments and have them be kind of
highlighted so that you can really see
as you scroll through your code
they really jump out at you and you can
see what is really useful there
so another great feature especially if
you're a javascript developer is there's
an extension called quoca
which gives you a javascript playground
and typescript
so if i run the quoka command i can do a
new javascript file
and then inside of here i've got like a
live javascript playpad or scratchpad or
whatever you want to call it
and i can type javascript right inside
of here and i can see the output over
here as well as
the output logged out over on this side
as well now this is
anytime i want to try out a new piece of
javascript this is my go to this is what
i use
the alternative would be to go into
google chrome for example or whatever
browser you use and open up the console
and type something
in here but that's not really convenient
when you're already inside
of your vs code editor and you already
know shortcuts and things and snippets
and stuff that you can use inside of vs
code so this is what i do
quoca is amazing for just a live scratch
pad for either javascript or typescript
another one that is great is the live
server extension
and if i search for this this is from
ripwickday and this has over
seven million downloads it's really
incredible
so if i typed in like a test.html here
and stubbed this out using my emmett
snippets and came down and said hello
world
one inside of this file i can do my
command palette and i can do live server
and you can open this with live server
and what this will do
is it will serve this on a real port so
we'll start up a
server serve this from a real port and i
can update
this file and as soon as i save now it's
reflected inside
of the browser as well because of that
live server extension
it handles all of that stuff for me
which is really really amazing
you'll definitely want to have this if
you're doing any sort of
basic html css and javascript stuff
installing that extension will make it
really easy to run that stuff
a couple of other nice ones there's a
polar code extension
this one allows you to take really sweet
looking images of your code so you
basically copy in some of your code you
can see
the example gif here you copy some of
your code you paste it in
and then polar code will generate this
really sweet looking snippet in here for
you
so that you can have pictures that you
can share on twitter
or in your blog post or things like that
there's also
the auto rename tag so if you do any
html
work again this one is really nice and
what this does
is if i start to update the
title here and make this an h1 notice
it's auto
updating the closing tag as well so
you'll definitely want to have
that extension to help you out with some
of some of your html stuff
and there's also the bracket pair
color riser and this one is pretty sweet
because inside of javascript this will
color
your brackets to match each other to
show you which one goes with each
so notice that we've got a purple color
here and then we've got a blue color
to show that this one goes with this one
this one with this one
and this one with this one this is
really nice it's kind of subtle but
especially when you're reading code and
having to do that
it's nice to just have it be pretty easy
to look at and see
really quickly all right so let me just
scroll through some of the other
extensions that i use that i think would
be useful for you
as well there's one here called
bookmarks this allows you to set
bookmarks in your code so if you're
working in
really really big files or a really big
project you can set bookmarks
inside of your files and then be able to
toggle through your bookmarks so if you
have like really important
spots inside of different pieces of code
you can mark those and then be able to
move through them using the commands
with this bookmark extension there's
also cloak this is a real
really nice one if you're working with
private credentials and you do screen
recordings like i do
uh cloak will take a dot env file so if
you use
env to have your environment variables
and they're private you don't want
people to see those which you probably
don't
you can turn on cloak and it will hide
those things from everybody that's
watching this is really useful
as it says here if you're presenting on
stage if you're streaming on twitch or
youtube
if you record screencasts of your code
like we do here
another nice one is csspeak this allows
you to
to view the css for a given
class or id so you can peak that where
you don't have to go all the way
over to the css file or if it's coming
from bootstrap or something like that
you don't have to open up the source
files
you can kind of see that right in line
in your code
next up we've got the debugger for
chrome this one we will actually have a
section on this coming up of debugging
inside of visual studio code and we'll
use this extension to do that
there's this dot env one this is pretty
simple but it just gives you kind of a
color syntax here for working with
environment variables inside of a dot
env file so if you've never done
environment variables if you've never
done
env files that's totally fine if you do
this one might be useful for you
next up is the editor config this is a
basic sort of formatting thing for your
code that you can use across different
types of
editors so if you have this dot editor
config file
you can use this and embed it in your
project and kind of make sure that your
projects stay
with a certain format across different
teams and people editing and that sort
of thing so this extension
enables that ability inside of vs code
if you are a react developer this is the
most popular react
extension that i know of with snippets
we'll talk about snippets more in a
second
for react redux graphql and react native
so there's lots of good stuff in there
that you can take advantage of
all right this is not maybe relevant to
everyone but i just wanted to kind of
highlight this extension here is for
fauna db
a great database option that you can use
for your applications and i just am
wanting to highlight here that there are
extensions for
lots of third-party technologies as well
so whether you use faunadb
or firebase or netlify or a ton of
different options out there you can
almost always find an extension so if
you have a product
a third-party product outside of
microsoft outside of vs code that you
work with
go and give it a shot to see if there's
something out there that you can find
import cost is another one that is great
for javascript developers this will
basically just show you
how big your import statements are so if
you look at
the example image that is not showing
here but if they had the example image
up it would show you that uh
you'll get some text right next to the
import statement to show you how big
that import is
that way you can make sure that you're
only importing the things that you
really need
and not anything extra
all right we've got the live share
extension down here this one will
actually have a section on in a minute
we've also got the markdown pdf this is
something i'm looking to
try out myself to create an ebook where
you can type markdown inside of vs code
and then be able to
export that to a pdf now speaking of
markdown just to kind of show you how
this works
in vs code you get some pretty good
support for markdown right inside of
here so if i open a markdown file here
is the source
but then i can also if i open
up the command palette i can open up a
preview to the side
so here's my markdown preview right in
line with all the markdown stuff that i
see
over here so i see source code as well
as a preview all
inside of the editor now i've used a few
different things for editing markdown
i've used stack edit which is in the
browser but this is really nice because
it's in the same place where i write my
code
and i can see that live preview right
there as well
so with that extension that i mentioned
you can take that markdown and then
export it to a pdf for
an e-book or something like that all
right and i think we've covered
the majority of the most important ones
here so again just know
the extension ecosystem in vs code is
great
there's tons of stuff there there's lots
of different options if you have an
idea for something go ahead and search
for it it's probably already there
all right now that we've covered
extensions let's talk about how to
customize your keyboard shortcuts and i
waited until we covered extensions
because some of these things you can
just kind of get
with an extension and take care of all
of that stuff for you
so if you hit this settings cog wheel
over here in the bottom left
you can open up your keyboard shortcuts
and as
always if you um open up your command
palette you could also do this from here
so
this preferences open keyboard shortcuts
will get you to the same
place and keyboard shortcuts in vs code
are really nice i think this is a pretty
powerful
thing for you to be able to customize so
as you would probably expect they have a
list of commands that you can then add a
key binding for
so add cursor above and then they show
you the
the shortcut here let's do let's search
for
search or actually let's do a find so
what is the shortcut for find we talked
about this earlier
it's command f or control f
and then you can see there's also lots
of different other options with
find as well where you can find previous
index and so on so this thing shows
that this command is going to be command
f and you can actually edit this right
in line which i think is pretty nice so
it's
pretty nice so if we um now specify
some weird combination of things so i'm
doing command
alt shift i that's probably not what i
want but then i press enter and now this
thing has been updated
and now i would need to press command
shift i to go ahead and find something
so let me go ahead and fix this back to
command
f that's what we really want all right
so that goes back to normal
and let's just search for another option
in here let's see if we
if we type select and then add selection
to next
find match so if you remember we
actually used this command
command d earlier to select a given word
so if you're inside of a word you can
use command d
to select it and go from there you can
also see in here we've got
x we've got shortcuts for this is
actually the bookmarks extension so that
bookmarks extension
that we talked about a few seconds ago
has its own keyboard shortcuts or
commands that you can add keyboard
shortcuts as well
so some extensions that you install will
have commands available
some of them will already have key
binding set to those some of them won't
have key binding set so you'll have to
go into the command palette to check
those out
all right one of the ones that i have
customized myself
and i kind of alluded to this early on
is the advanced new file so when i want
to create a new file if i come back to
let me close out some of these
extensions
when i come into a file and i press
command n this is going to ask me where
i want to create the file and i can say
root and then i can say test
dot something and that's going to create
that file and open it inside of vs code
which is a really nice workflow now let
me show you what happens if i don't have
that set
so if i if i just remove this key
binding by right click and then remove
key binding
that will go away and then if i press
command n inside of here
it doesn't do exactly what i want where
it creates this new file but it doesn't
have a name
and it doesn't it's not in a directory
anywhere so i would then need to go and
save that file
directly so that's why i like having
that advanced new file
extension and then specifically set to
that key binding
now i can just update the one that is
here so this advanced new file i can
just do this
and now say command n and that thing
should be okay and notice also that when
i did that
it's telling me that three commands
already have this binding so this will
allow me to know
that there are some commands already
have this and i need to double check hey
do i really want to do this
and then vs code is smart enough to know
that this command down here the new
untitled file
that's the one that i show you showed
you that for me is not really optimal
so this is a default source and then
mine the one that i created up here is a
user source so it's going to take
precedence over the one
that comes default with vs code so it
handles the overriding of these commands
really well
all right so there's my uh new file and
then if i trigger this now with command
n
and notice that there's no delay here
this automatically reloads as soon as i
update the command
shortcuts now they're available for me
to use
another thing that i want to show you is
if we come down here and we'll talk
about the built-in terminal here in a
minute
but if we look at this last one not only
does it have a command and a key binding
it also has a win now this is basically
a win is basically a state that you can
use
inside of vs code to determine when this
shortcut should take place which makes
the combination of shortcuts very
powerful so let's look up vs code
shortcuts and i want to show you just so
you can be able to go out and look at
these
later on for yourself if you need to
do some extra research on how to do this
so let's search for
the when and i'm scrolling down here to
the when clause context so you can do
some conditional things in here when the
editor language id equals typescript so
if you're specifically in a typescript
file a command might do something
specific versus another one
if you're on linux or if you're on
windows
you can detect that way and so on and so
on so then you come down and you can see
all the different contacts the things
that you can use
to determine when your your shortcut
should be triggered
based on that key binding so if the
editor is focused if you're actually
focused on the editor if the editor has
selection meaning
you've already selected a piece of text
if you scroll down you see the operating
systems
is windows mac linux there's also an is
web because there's a lot of embedded
versions of vs code inside of the
browser which is pretty cool
and then you've got some different modes
here we'll talk about debugging here in
a second there's so many different
options in here for you to choose from
this gives you kind of the ultimate
ability to customize when your shortcuts
should be triggered
now notice that i've got these three key
bindings here
and again vs code is smart enough to
know when to trigger each one so because
i have
this advanced new file as a user source
it takes precedent over
the default source here and then this
command
in when the terminal is focused so when
i'm actually down here in this terminal
will take precedence over that if i'm
actually focused on the terminal
so vs code already has this ability to
kind of take
your commands that you define and then
add precedence on top of them
so now that you know how to customize
all those shortcuts and again there's
tons in here you can scroll through you
can search for what you want and just
customize it to your heart's content
after you have that or maybe even before
you have that it's interesting to know
that there are some key map
extensions in the marketplace as well so
if for instance you come from
sublime so you use sublime text for
several years you come over to vs code
and the shortcuts aren't exactly what
you're looking for
well the sublime text keymap and
settings importer
that can actually import settings from
sublime and then also basically
override all of your shortcuts to match
what should have been
or what would have been inside of
sublime that way you can keep the same
shortcuts that you're used to
and you can kind of go about your
business just like you you had in the
past
now there's sublime i wonder if there's
notepad plus plus
notepad plus plus keymap there's that
one i wonder if there is
atom keymap all the different yep
there's atom keymap there
and then there's probably brackets as a
key map maybe there's not brackets as a
key map but
you can find for most of those popular
editors text editors you can find a key
map
extension that you can just bring right
in and then go about your business just
like you had in the past so
that is the section on customizing
shortcuts the other thing i want to talk
about customizing is your snippets
so if we look inside of
just the javascript file down here i'm
going to show you a couple of snippets
that are kind of built into vs code so
if i type clg
notice vs code is now popping up with
this snippet here and it shows me what
it's going to output so it's going to
output a console.log so there's
a snippet there and we talked about all
the intellisense that vs code gives you
so if we do document dot and then get
element by id something like that we can
go ahead and complete so vs code gives
you some built-in snippets
and then some intellisense on knowing
what functions and things are available
but if you want to customize and add
your own snippets
you can also do that so the way
that snippets work is snippets get
stored inside of a json file
and if we click on the cogwheel and go
to user snippets or if we just open the
command palette and open
snippets as well configure user snippets
it's going to
ask you which type of language are you
working with so you can have
global snippets which apply just
anywhere regardless of what file you're
in
and or you can have snippets that are
specific to certain languages so if we
look down
at the javascript.json i've actually got
a few of these that i use
in my code and i'll kind of walk you
through how those work
so let's just start off with the the
very basic here
of the console log example so if i
wanted to have a new snippet
for doing a console log statement i
would one give this kind of a title
or a key here and this could be jq
console
log and then that thing is going to
point to or
have a value of an object that will have
different properties
so the first thing is the prefix and
this is going to be what is the short
code that you want to use
to trigger this snippet now this is not
super practical i'm just using this to
differentiate between the other clg but
let's do a prefix here of jq
clg for console log and then
we'll do the body and the body here is
going to be a string
so we'll do the body is console
and then we'll have the description so
if we needed some extra details in here
this will write a console log statement
so pretty straightforward so after you
save that thing
now this snippet is ready for you to use
so inside of my javascript file it
doesn't matter what javascript file i'm
in
i can type jq and notice i get the
prefix here of
popping up the intellisense for my
snippet and it shows me the description
over here
and it shows me what it's actually going
to write so if i press enter now it
actually writes out that log statement
now a couple of things we might want to
update instead of ending with my cursor
over here
i might want to actually end with my
cursor in the middle
so that i can type in the input for that
console log
so one of the things you can do is
something called tab stops so if i do a
dot or a dollar sign
one here this is saying that i'm going
to be entering
in some pieces of information and this
is the first one that i'm going to enter
so now if i do the same thing jqc log
and press enter now you see my it puts
my cursor there
so i can type in my object is what i
want to log
and then come over and maybe i want to
actually include a semicolon
and then after i finish entering in the
information here i want to go down to
the next line which can get kind of
interesting so
a couple of things let's go ahead and
add this semicolon
and then if you're doing snippets that
have multiple lines you need to put them
in an array so you have an array
of strings so there's the first string
there and the second one
is going to be on a new line so we can
have that be tab stop two for example
so let's try this out again and uh let's
trigger the snippet with jq
clg press enter type in my object and
then
tab will take me to the next tab stop
now you can have as many tab stops as
you want
the interesting thing about this one is
the dollar sign zero is actually going
to be the very last place that you
end so after you finish all of your tab
stops that are one through
x or y or n or however many you do
dollar sign
zero is going to be the very last
snippet so that's going to be where your
cursor goes
after you've finished all the previous
tab stops so let's save this let's do
the same this will do the same thing i
just want to show you the tab stop of
zero there so jq
clg and type in my object and then
return or tab
actually and that will bring me down to
this next line
so that's a pretty simple example and
these can obviously get a lot more
complicated
here's an example actually another
simple example of using environment
variables
and i do this a lot where if you're
using environment variables you have to
type out process.env.something
and maybe you don't want to have to do
that so i created this this extension
the snippet
that is just env and that will replace
it with process.env
and then i can type in the actual
variable that i'm working with
all right and if i scroll up a little
bit let's scroll up to the top a couple
of the ones that i like
here is a used hook in react this may be
completely new to you
so don't worry if this is new but same
thing here it's got kind of the key here
the title it's got a prefix it doesn't
have a description because i didn't add
one
but then it's got the body and it has
two tab stops so here is one
and tab stop two oh actually three tab
stops here's tab top three and then tap
stop zero
goes to the end of the line and then i
could return to get down to the next one
now here's a great example of one that
would uh be really useful and they have
one
built in to vs code if we type in four
there's a couple of different for loop
snippets so here's one that comes from
vs code
itself and then here's the one that i
created which is 4r
f-o-r-a-r-r so inside of here you can
see this is
a multi-line snippet because it's got an
array
and each line or each item in the array
is a string
and so we we define a pretty standard
for loop that uses an array
so it says dollar index well we haven't
seen this yet we've seen dollar zero one
two three four and so on
you can instead of using numbers with
your dollar sign you can actually give
them a name
and this will allow you to repeat this
same variable in multiple places so what
this looks like is if i show you
if i trigger this snippet 4r
i press enter notice there's multiple
cursors now so there's a cursor here
here here and here that's because that
index that
i probably is what you're going to use
it for
is repeated in several places because we
gave it a name so if i type in i
now it's going to replace that in every
location which is really nice
and then i press tab well now if we look
back at the snippet
now we've got our array tab stop and
that's used twice too because it's named
so now we can type in
my r that's going to be the name of my
array and then i can tab
over again and then i come down to the
end of my snippet so this is a really
fun way
or not i mean it is fun it is cool but
this is a really practical way
of being able to use that same value in
a couple of different locations
here's another example of that one of
the things that i use a lot in vanilla
javascript is the
document.getelementbyid
and usually typically the id of that
element is the same
name variable name that i want to call
it inside of javascript
so i use this snippet to grab that value
here
and then reference it here as well so
it's going to use the same thing so
let's
go ahead and trigger this snippet with
git
id and this is going to write that whole
thing out and i'll say my
cool dom element and notice that
completes at the end as well and then i
tab
down to the end of the line because
that's where it ends all right i've got
a few in here for an event listener and
then for me
especially inside of doing a
fetch request i always have to do a
fetch and then surround it with a
try-catch to handle errors and then log
out the air
get the data back from the fetch if i
want wanted to so here's an
another example of of me just thinking
about something that i write all the
time
that would really help me by having a
snippet i could just do that right in
here
so if i run this snippet it goes ahead
and writes all of that code for me i can
tell it i want to get
the data from coolapi.com
and then tab and then now i've got all
that stuff taken care of now i can just
go ahead and handle
the response so i would say snippets are
one of the most powerful features inside
of vs code anytime you see yourself
writing a bunch of code over and over
again and it never really changes
you might think about or a lot of it
doesn't change you might think about how
to use snippets
or define snippets inside of your
snippets json file
so that you can save yourself some time
and effort later on
all right now that we've talked about
settings and themes and a bunch of
different aspects of vs code i want to
talk about what previously was an
extension if we search in here the
settings sync
extension now this is a really cool
extension that came out a while ago
where you could download this extension
and it would save
all of the customizations that you've
done inside of vs code
into a gist inside of github
and what i mean is it will take all of
your configurations your snippets your
shortcuts your settings
your extensions it will take all of
those things and then save them
basically in a file
and then you could use that file or
share that file across different
instances
of vs code so that if i went to another
computer
opened up vs code i could sync my
settings settings sync here
and then i could have all that stuff
ready to go so let's let me open up my
github
and then i'll open up my gist to show
you what i'm talking about so i scroll
down to
jest and then come down here to cloud
settings now this is where
the settings sync extension will save
all of those things
and if i open this up you'll notice i
have a few different files
so i've got cloud settings this is just
for like metadata of when the last time
i updated and what version i think i was
on for that extension
and then i've got a file here for all
the different extensions that i use
actually i think this is an uh not the
correct one let me open up this one
this has all the stuff so inside of my
extensions.json this lists out every
single
extension that i had installed notice
notice this is a pretty big file
so all of my extensions would be ready
to go all of my custom key bindings if i
had some
which i do here for mac all those custom
key bindings come over
the settings that i've overridden with
vs code the
snippets that i've created we talked
about a lot of those snippets here for
markdown as well
and python all those things that we've
talked about so far you want to be able
to use
on different instances of vs code if you
have to go to another computer
so up until recently the setting sync
extension was the way to go to be able
to do that but now
this is something that is built into vs
code so let's come in
to settings and i'm going to go actually
i've got a tab
open here and if i look in this bottom
left i've got this icon here for my
account
and this says settings sync is on and
one of the things i'm gonna do to show
you how this works is search for
setting sync and then turn this off and
i'll turn this off now and notice inside
of vs code this is what you'll see when
you open up your settings window you'll
see this button here for turn on
settings sync
now what this is going to do is vs code
is basically going to manage all this
stuff for you behind the scenes
and make sure that it does the same
thing that we just talked about with
this third party extension
but built into vs code so if i click on
turn on settings sync
it asks me what things i want to
actually synchronize
and this is yes my settings my shortcuts
my user snippets my extensions my ui
state
so i'll select all those and i click
turn on and then you'll either have to
log in with your github or your
microsoft account now i've already
logged in
in the past so this is basically kind of
auto completing that login process you
will be taken to github
have to log in with your github
credentials and then you'll be brought
back here
and you can see this says that setting
sync is turned on
if i look at i don't need those details
there but if i come over
to now my little window here and look it
says that i'm logged in with github and
this thing is turned on which is pretty
nice now i can also
if i look at the search for settings
sync again
as well and come down to show sync data
there's a little tab here that it will
open to show me
the recent synchronization that has
happened as well as the machines that
are synced
with this setting or with these settings
so
if i had vs code on multiple different
machines
i would see in here which ones are
synchronized
i could refresh this to get a new list i
could edit this name so that i could be
more specific about which one i'm
working with
and then i could also turn off settings
sync on different ones so if i didn't
want
all of my things to be synced across
different
instances of vs code i could turn that
off on some of them and keep it on
on others and notice here that in the
activity
uh this shows me that 35 seconds ago 35
that these things were updated and it
gives me just a pretty cool view of what
all is going on in here all right so
again previously you would have had to
jump for another extension
now with this built-in setting sync you
can do this right inside of vs code not
have to grab a third-party
extension and be good to go with making
sure that all of your things are stored
across different instances
of vs code now i took a second on here
to
bring up another instance of vs code
i've actually got the vs code
regular edition the stable edition open
is what we've been working with
and then now i've got open the vs code
insiders edition as well
and this thing has our settings sync
turned on as well so if we look at the
show synced data tab you can see it's
been doing these synchronizations and
you can see on both sides there's two
different machines that have been synced
there's the vs code which one is this
let's make this a little bit bigger
so mac number one that's the current and
there's the insiders mac over
here so those things are synced and
what's cool is if i come in and search
for
theme and then go to toggle my theme and
i want to change it to something
uh what crackpot contrast sure let's do
that
and press enter notice it changed over
here and then if i scroll back over
it should change on this instance of vs
code as well so notice
it took a few seconds but that came
through really really cool and then i
could change this back
to cobalt 2 and then this
should be able to now update over here
in a few seconds as well
and you saw that come through so the
settings sync extension is
super super powerful it's really cool
because now real time you can see these
things change
and make sure that you never miss any of
your settings in vs code
all right now i want to take a look at
debugging inside of vs code this is one
of the most powerful and probably
underrated features in vs code
so i'm going to open up this this
project here which is a vanilla html css
and javascript project i'm going to open
this one up
and i actually added a couple of test
files here that don't have anything in
them i don't need
so i'm going to delete those and then
i'm going to open up my html file
and with that go live extension that we
talked about earlier
i'm gonna open this with a live server
so this will open it at port 5500 and
send me to the index.html page
now what this demo is is the ability to
take a color and then lighten and darken
it so if i enter in
some sort of color and here i can
then lighten or it looks like that type
that in wrong
should be d so here's my red color i can
darken that color or i can then take
that color and lighten it down to
basically a white
so this is vanilla javascript and i want
to show you how we can actually debug
this so let's open up our javascript
file
and let's just look at one of these
functions here this toggle button so
when we click on that toggle button
we're applying and removing some classes
to do the styling on here so notice the
color changes
and then this little piece in the middle
changes color as well as moves over to
the right or the left depending on which
side
it's toggled to so i look at my debug
tab
this little bug and play button here and
it's got a run and debug button here and
it's going to ask me this is kind of a
new feature inside of vs code where i
can now choose where am i going to run
this thing while i'll run it in chrome
and it went ahead and created a
configuration in here of where this
thing is going to run
so i'm going to say this is going to run
at 5500 because that's where it
is running now so with that in place
once i press this button it's going to
open up
that application to 5500 and now
debugging is enabled so that i can debug
right inside of vs code
so notice i've got this menu button up
here none of these things are really
active because we don't have breakpoints
set and we aren't paused
for debugging so what this looks like is
inside of vs code
to the left of the numbers i can now add
breakpoints so there's a little
breakpoint there
and when i click this toggle button it
should then trigger that breakpoint
inside of vs code so we'll click this
now it goes away from chrome comes over
to vs code and hits right at that break
point
now if you're new to debugging this may
be a lot
but the alternative to this is typically
people will just kind of do console log
statements
instead of true debugging but true
debugging is incredibly powerful
so with this thing paused at this line
now some of these buttons here are
enabled so i could play and this would
just say all right go ahead and continue
as you were and it goes to darken now
let's click it again
instead of play we can come down
and we can step over so we can go
through line by line
and see what's going on notice that
skipped that else and then
now that we're at a function that we
have this reset function
that comes down here instead of skipping
over that line
we can actually step into so step n2
will go inside of that function and go
through or allow us to
go through line by line here so i could
go through and go
line by line and then i could continue
when i was ready but one of the things i
want to show you
is that you can inspect variables in
here so if we look at
our script actually i can see all of the
different elements that i have created
inside of my javascript inside of this
script inside of this javascript file
so if i look for this input color for
example i can scroll down
and i can see the input color and it
shows me what selector that thing is and
then i can look at
here's all the different properties and
functions associated with that
so you can see i've got all of these in
here
as well as the functions that i've
created so i can inspect all of these
variables and then you can choose one of
those variables
and tell it to watch for that thing so
if i say
watch for the toggle
button here's my toggle button and if i
click the play
in here and then i click this again i
come back to my debugging
and then i click this toggle again now
it's going to show me right off here
since i'm watching for this variable now
i see it
right now and i can see that it doesn't
have the class of toggle
so i'll go ahead and play and then if i
come back and i toggle this thing again
now we should see that it has the class
of toggle so this is actually an
interesting way
to i could check for dom elements to see
if classes are being applied
as opposed to let me make sure i play
this again as opposed to coming into
inspect and then going into the element
itself and looking inside of there i
could see this inside of my watch
so overall debugging in vs code is very
powerful it's one of those features that
is highly underrated and very very
useful for you so that is an example of
debugging kind of vanilla javascript i
also want to show you an example of
debugging something in node
as well all right so i've got a new
application
open this is design and build a chat app
with
socket i o and node.js so you can
actually grab this code on github if
you're interested and there is a video
series on youtube on how to build this
as well but with this stuff here i made
sure to install the packages
and i cd into my part 8 directory which
is really where i want to be because
that's the final step of this project
so if i open up the debug tab here
and let me make sure that i can open
this server.js because it told me i
needed to open up a javascript file
and then i come to debug and let's say
run and debug
and then i'll click node i didn't really
have to do anything
extra but now this thing is ready to go
and if we open up our browser to
localhost
3000 we should see now this application
is up and running
and it actually works so this thing is
running our application now we should be
able to set a debug point
and do the same sort of thing like we
did before so let's do
a debug breakpoint on the
message handler so when a message
actually comes through let's set a
breakpoint and let's trigger it and then
come back over here so let's try to type
out a message
hey this is james and press send
this now hit that break point and we can
do the same things we did before look at
variables set watches
i didn't talk about this but you can see
the call stack this shows you the
history
of the functions that were called and
then i had the ability to step
in step through all those sort of things
as well as just go ahead and click the
play
and it will go ahead and send that
message so just wanted to add on here a
small example
of what it's like to debug an
application that uses node not just
small javascript
but the cool thing is that vs code makes
that really easy for you regardless
all right we've mentioned this a few
times but vs code has
a built-in terminal you've actually seen
this a little bit right inside of vs
code that i want to talk about as well
so i want to say that a lot of or some
people don't prefer
to use the built-in terminal in vs code
they prefer to have a separate window
for their terminal
i'll tell you that my personal
preference is that i really enjoy having
the terminal built right into vs code
so that i i can do everything that i
need to in my editor and not have to
worry about other applications
so as you would probably expect you can
do everything inside of this terminal
that you would in
your regular terminal so i use an
application called hyper that's what i
use for my terminal
and if you're on mac you'll have like
the built-in mac terminal if you're on
windows you might have
you might have powershell or command
prompt or
git bash or things like that but this is
my terminal
and it uses zsh instead of
bash so zsh is actually the default
shell on my computer
so yours will pick up your default shell
and i think this is zsh has probably
become the default shell on mac
in the last couple of months but
regardless you'll see which shell you
have
here to be able to use and you can
select your default one if you need to
change it
but this is going to open up and have
basically the same experience that you
would have
inside of your regular terminal which is
really really nice
now a couple of things i want to show
you on here is you can have multiple
instances of your terminal you can set
them side by side which is kind of cool
i don't really use this myself and the
reason is that i
end up having multiple tabs
inside of my terminal but not side by
side so what i mean is let me kill this
one
if i do the plus over here this is going
to do a new tab so you can see now i
have this drop down between one
and two and so this is how i usually
work with mine
but then i did some shortcuts on here to
customize this and make this a little
bit easier to work with
so i customized my shortcuts to be able
to use the same way i would use
up here if i have two different files
the control and tab to be able to toggle
through them
i have that set up as a custom shortcut
for my terminal
as well so now i can tab through these
and not have to worry about
losing out on space by having them side
by side but
if you have enough space on your
computer and it seems to work out well
you can do a split
and you can also have multiple of these
so three four
five you can kind of get crazy with this
and it's probably not very practical at
that point
but it's something that you can do now
you also have this little button to go
ahead and expand this
all the way up which is kind of nice
there's also
control and command and up or down will
kind of
increase the size of this or decrease
the size of this by
a little bit to make it a little bit
bigger or a little bit smaller so i
happen to use that one a lot as well
now you notice on this delete over here
if i hover
on kill terminal it it says command w
that's not a built in command that's one
that i customize
for my experience as well that way it
will match
the command w or control w on windows
that i use to close files up here i can
close tabs just the same
inside of my terminal so again i've done
some customization to make sure that
this works exactly how i would expect
and the other thing
i think you should know is that control
and tilde will toggle
open this terminal so we mentioned early
on that i use command or control b to
close that side panel
i also do control and tilde to open and
close the terminal
that way i can have a lot of space for
my code if i need the terminal i do
control
tilde and then if i need the sidebar i
do command b
getting used to those shortcuts is
really really useful
all right and then if i come into the
settings in here as well you notice we
have lots of
settings or a handful of settings for
the terminal as well
all right so if we search terminal and
then i'm going to click on the terminal
category here
all right if i scroll down and start to
look at some of the settings associated
with terminal
keep scrolling down let's get to some of
the fun ones one you can customize what
your
shell is so if you want to customize
that based on the operating system that
you're on you can do that
so let's look at there's a cursor style
so we can have the block or a line and
notice this becomes a lot thinner
you can have a cursor width so i could
change this and make this a lot bigger
five alright so and i think actually the
one is kind of interesting
you can also have this cursor blink so
similar to how we had our cursor
acting inside of our code now this thing
will blink when i have
it focused on i'm going to scroll down
and grab a few more of these
settings you can change your font family
and
font in here and actually i need to
update this to cascadia
code because i had used and this may
need to go inside of quotes
because i had used fear code in the past
and now
i'm using cascadia code although i think
i'm getting a little bit of an odd thing
there so let's
check back to fear code and that goes
away so i'll just leave fear code there
you can change the font so if you wanted
the font size and your terminal to be a
little bit
bit bigger or smaller you could do that
as well so very similar to how you do
inside of regular text font weight of
bold
line height letter spacing if i did a 10
for letter spacing this will space
things out a lot
probably not what we want but you get
the ability to customize those things
right inside of here
which is actually pretty nice and i
think there is a
terminal position or location
default location so this this controls
the default location of the panel
which includes the terminal the debug
button and so on and this can either be
at the bottom right or left of the
workbench so if you wanted to put this
on either side
you could do that as well it looks like
we've still got our debugging session up
so i'm gonna go ahead and kill that
so anyway inside of your built-in
terminal one i would recommend
knowing how to toggle that open and
closed so you only have it open when you
need it
know that you can create multiple
instances of your terminal by adding the
plus or by setting them side by side
you can close them you can make this
full screen close that back down here
and once you get used to kind of
navigating that and working with it
alongside of your code i think you'll
really really enjoy it the way that i do
all right so we've got our debugging
section is out of the way we've got the
built-in terminal
out of the way now let's take a look at
some of the get
integrations so inside of here we've got
the source control tab and this is
actually telling me that i've already
got a file that has changed so
let's open up i'm going to open up a
different project let's open up a recent
let's go back to that quick colors one
and uh yes this is actually asking me if
i want to
kill a terminal session yes i'm okay
with that and let's come back in here
and notice that this part is red if i do
a get or not red but yellow
if i do a git status notice it's telling
me that some things have changed
so all the things that i could do down
here so if i did a get a net and
actually maybe that's worth doing so
let's go
back out here let's go into
our delete delete me folder and let's do
a make dear of
test get and then i'm going to open that
thing up so
i'm going to open up the test
test kit and let's just see this inside
of vs code so
what i would probably do if i wanted
this to be a git repository is i would
run a git init command
well in vs code you can actually do that
right inside of here so
if i come to the source control it says
do i want to initialize this repository
uh yeah let's go ahead and do that and
that will basically run this get a nit
command
so then i could come in and add a file
so test.html or something and use our
bang
to get an html file and so i would come
into
the terminal run a git status i would
see that this file needs to be added
i would do git add test html git commit
and so on but i could come in and see
this as well
and notice that not only do i have the
ability to stage these changes or
add them i also have the ability to add
a commit message
and revert this file if we look at this
kind of backward squirly arrow i can
discard those changes
as well as open the file and see the
differences and this is really cool
so let's do a couple of things let's go
ahead and stage this file
and then we'll go ahead and commit this
and say added test.html
and uh do the checkbox here all right so
that thing has been added now
let's add in a title uh working with
git and we'll see that this file has
changed again
and now notice if i click on this i see
a very cool
diff to show me exactly what's changed
so vs code i think is is one of the best
diff tools being able to see the
differences
visually in different in files that have
changed
vs code does a great way of just kind of
laying these out and showing you what's
changed
which i think is really neat so from
there i could go through that same
process let's stage this thing and then
updated the test.html file
all right so with that in place i'll
click the check and we're good to go
now one other thing that uh vs code
allows you to do
now that they are or microsoft bought
github
there's even better integration here
where i don't have this
actually created in a repository
i don't have this created as an actual
repository in github so
one of the things that i can do is
scroll down to the publish to github
command
this is really neat because right here i
can say publish to github
it can i can choose between a private
and a public repository
so if i do a public repository it's
asking me which file should be in there
my index or my test
html yes and this is going to say
publish to github
it's already published this is a github
repository if i come over to my github
now
and search in my repositories let's pull
up the full list of repositories here
now we should see this test get now this
has always been or has been
for me in the past an issue where i
would have to come into github create
the repository and then go through these
steps
now these things are taken care of from
inside of vs code so this repository is
created
now i can push this code to that
repository
and i guess we need to add our remote
and we'll add the remote
from github and then we'll choose this
repository that we just created
and we'll name this as origin and that
should go ahead and push
all that code out all that code is just
one file but push that file out to
and now if we refresh that repository we
see that stuff got added
up here so from inside of vs code i can
do my basic get workflow
and then i can also create repositories
inside of github
instead of having to to go to github
directly
this is really really powerful and i
want to scroll back over to
my project here if we look at i've got
some things that have changed
i've got a launch.json this is for that
debugging stuff that we checked out
and then i've made some changes if we
scroll down and i could look at these
individually if i wanted to i could
scroll up and see the app css see the
things that have changed there as well
i'm not going to do anything with those
changes because i don't need to right
now
but you have the full ability to do all
the things that you're used to
add commit push clone pull
you can check out different branches you
can see i've got the branch selected
here i can create a new branch i can
choose a different one if i wanted to
do all that stuff right inside of vs
code now one thing i do want to show you
on top of that
is vs code has some amazing built-in
support for git but it also has
extensions that can help you as well and
get lens to me
is the most powerful extension out there
you can look at
let's open a file and see this so if i
open that app.js
and then open up the get lens extension
i can see
the file history so what the different
commits were if i select a line i can
see the history based on that line and
the different commits that were
made with that i can look at how many
different branches and contributors and
remotes and stashes and tags and things
that i have
also if you look at this text over here
that is get blame text which comes from
this extension which will show me that i
edited this file three months ago or
this line three months ago
in a commit that had a refactoring code
as the commit
and so not only does it show you in line
over here if you hover on that
now you get this extra detail and you
can go and actually click on the commit
click on the person if i wanted to and
it opened up
actually it opened up an email on
another monitor but i can see a lot of
different
uh information about the commits the
history
i can see the same thing down here and
then i get lots of options
to open those files to show the commit
and the search commits view
to open the commit and github all these
different things
this is by far the most powerful
extension for working with git inside of
vs code i highly recommend checking it
out
and then on top of that's on top of
already the really amazing built-in
features
inside of vs code all right the last
thing i want to show you is one of the
coolest and most powerful features in vs
code and that is the live share
extension so let's come to extensions
and let's search for
live share and i think you'll be blown
away if you've never seen this before of
what it does
what this does is it allows me to share
my code live with someone so that we can
have like a live
peer programming session remotely we
could be across the world we could share
code we could talk through code
we could do all these things right with
this live share extension
inside of vs code so you want to make
sure you have that extension installed
and then i'll type in the command
palette live share
and i'm going to scroll down
to find the start collaboration session
so when i do that i'll need to log in
with github i'm already logged in in
this case so i can just copy
this link so it copies it for me or i
can copy it again and i'm going to come
over to my other instance of vs code
and i'm going to trigger this with live
share join collaboration session so
let's join this and i'll need to
sign in here as well so i'll sign in
with my github account
with my james quick github i'll go ahead
and authorize that thing you'll need to
go through this process as well
it'll redirect me back to vs code and i
say all right that's good to go
and then i'll need to actually trigger
this again so it actually grab here is
the session that i'm trying to join
i'm pasting this from this other
instance of vs code over here the one
that i started it on
and so i'll press enter in here and uh
active terminal session
yes i'll kill it i actually want to turn
that off so let's search for
terminal kill vs code is going to need
some permissions
on my computer to make this work i also
want to change that setting for the
terminal
to not prompt yeah confirm on exit so i
want to turn that off okay
now you can see i didn't have this quick
colors project
open on this side it was only open on
the other
instance of vs codes let me grab that so
here
here the code is and i can toggle around
i can move my cursor and notice
that inside of here this is my cursor on
the insider's edition and here's the
cursor
from the person in this case this
instance that created
the share session so i can see this real
time and i can follow the person
as they navigate through code so if i
open up a new file
this will can if i choose open up the
new file here as well
and the way that works is with this pin
so if i use this pin
i can follow this person around as they
scroll through code
and change files notice that scrolling
and changing files and i'm not even
doing anything
so one person could kind of teach
and show and walk through code while the
other person just follows you can turn
that off you can both
both work on code at the same time you
can share a terminal
you can do all sorts of things with vs
code liveshare this is such a cool
extension to have enabled
for you to do peer programming with
someone across the world or someone
that's maybe on the same computer as i'm
doing in this demo
regardless of how you use it this is one
of the coolest and most powerful
features
inside of vs code you should definitely
check it out it's very useful
for being able to do peer debugging or
code review sessions
it's flat out amazing all right i just
want to do a quick
recap here and just kind of talk about
how i think and most
or many people think that vs code is the
best the most popular
the most powerful editor for lots of
different things but specifically for
web development is where it will really
really shine
we covered lots of different features of
vs code we looked at downloading the
stable edition the
insider's edition and the difference
between those two we looked at
the layout and how to customize it and
really optimize the view
in vs code for you as a developer so
that you can write code as fast as
possible
another thing we talked about getting
into speed is how to use those shortcuts
you want to keep your hands
off of the mouse as much as possible
keep your hands on the keyboard so
learning those shortcuts in vs code is
really really
crucial knowing how to toggle open your
menu bars and how to navigate text
quickly
and shortcuts for opening and closing
and saving files and things like that
is really really going to save you a ton
of time and then we started to get into
a lot of the customization aspects of vs
code and there are lots of ways to
customize it which is my favorite thing
about vs code
it's built with electron it's built with
html css and javascript so you can make
changes and immediately see those things
take place so some of the things we
looked at are just some of your built-in
settings
things like your font family i use
cascadia.js i used to use spherocode you
can get those free on github if you
search for them and install them
and then i use font ligatures to be able
to have those fancy characters for
arrows and different things like that
looked at font size and zoom size and
there's a ton of different features or
settings in vs code that you can
customize and the cool thing is they
make it really easy for you to customize
them as well
we also looked at customizing your key
maps of being able to
for you to define what you want your
shortcuts to be so i think vs code has a
lot of great built-in shortcuts
but if you have ways that you want to
customize that you can certainly do that
too
in addition to that once we got into
extensions you can see that they have
keymap
extensions that you can download and
port in key maps from other editors like
sublime
or notepad or things like that so that
you can keep those
shortcuts that you're used to and then
we covered a list of really useful
extensions ones that i use every day the
live
server extension is one that i do
literally use almost every day
the advanced new file extension the
color uh pair
the color the bracket pair colorizer
extension all of these that we walk
through are really great they're ones
that i use all the time
we looked at themes i used the cobalt 2
theme there's winter is coming
and there's night owl by sarah drazner
there's a ton you can just search for
drain or
dreams themes and really customize those
to make them your own
and then we got into some of the deeper
features in vs code being able to do
debugging right inside of
your editor not having to go to the
browser doing break points
and walking through files we did that in
vanilla javascript or front end
javascript as well as node
vs code just makes this really really
easy and then we moved on
to source control integration of or
working with
git inside of vs code it's got great
built-in tools for working with
repositories locally
for working with remote repositories in
github and then we talked about the get
lens extension on top of that
to really supercharge your git workflow
and then lastly
we took a look at the live share
extension
which allows you to write code real time
or share code real time or walk through
code real time
with someone across the world wherever
they are
in the same editor you can see each
other's cursor you can follow each other
around stuff like that
so that is really really impactful for
code reviews and teaching and learning
uh working with someone on code so all
in all vs code
is the best editor that's out there for
web development and for a lot of things
i highly recommend it i hope this crash
course helps and thanks for checking out
the video